sa ligue menthe à l'eau ici le
commissaire fabien aujourd'hui je vous
fait passer un test pour intégrer le
syli fbi à youtube ou je sais pas quoi
hier j'ai reçu par mail une énigme de
mike mike qui habite à dublin mike tu
peux commenter pour dire oui c'est bien
moi qui t'ai envoyé un mail
j'ai trouvé son énigme tellement
intéressante que je vous en fait part
aujourd'hui comme si c'était un test
pour rentrer en tant que mentalist dans
la police et ça rime
ce qui est amusant c'est que j'ai trouvé
une réponse à cette énigme et quand mike
m'a envoyé sa réponse c'est pas la même
donc c'est cool
en fin de vidéo je vous donnerai les
deux réponses mais essayez de la trouver
par vous même avant ces sommes beaucoup
mieux
imaginez vous être enfermés dans une
salle devant vous il ya une bombe qui
est prête à exploser le compteur tourne
pour la désactiver il faut que vous
entriez un code vous n'avez qu'une seule
chance en cas d'erreur la bombe explose
devant la bombe
il ya trois personnes et ces trois
personnes dont un tee shirt et sur le
tee shirt ya marqué un code l'un des
codes et le bon mais on vous a prévenu
ces trois personnes sont légèrement
dérangé il y en a un il dit tout le
temps la vérité il dit la vérité quoi
qu'il arrive on l'appelle dans le métier
l'honnête y en a un autre dans le tas on
ne sait pas lequel rien ne les
différencie
il ment tout le temps quand ils arrivent
on l'appelle le filou devrait pas
forcément appelé le film home et mike
l'appeler le fil ou alors je l'appelle
le fil oup de troisième des fois il ment
des fois il dit la vérité
des fois il dit deux fois la vérité
d'affilée on sait jamais ce qu'il va
dire pourquoi parce qu'il s'en fout on
l'appelle l'indécis les trois entre eux
savent qui est qui y'a juste vous qu'ils
ne savaient pas qui est qui vous ne
pouvez pas les différencier vous jetez
un oeil sur le compte à rebours et vous
comprenez que vous avez juste le temps
de poser trois questions avant que la
bombe explose alors va falloir être bon
efficace sur ces trois questions un
flash à parer votre dernier souvenir
c'est d'avoir appuyé sur le bouton
désamorçage de la bombe car vous avez
réussi à désamorcer la bombe
la police arrive sur les lieux vous dis
mais comment vous avez réussi à
déterminer qui était qui avec seulement
trois questions et c'est vrai comment
vous avez réussi
sachant que vous avez comme information
que c'est celui qui dit toujours la
vérité qui a le bon code sur son tee
shirt vous laisse réfléchir à ça je
donne ma réponse est celle de mike à la
fin après la outreau j'espère que vous
allez faire partie du si vieille fbi
ayew ce que tu veux qui finit en ail et
surtout que cette nouvelle vidéo vous a
plu si c'est le cas vous ne le fait
savoir en laisser un petit pouce en
l'air c'est très important et n'oubliez
également de vous abonner avant de
partir puisque le mental vote c'est une
vidéo par jour pendant un an donc rendez
vous demain à 17h ciao
alors je commence par vous donner ma
réponse
on va imaginer que les trois personnes
sont dans un ordre précis
donc on va appeler 1 2 et 3 j'aime
adressé au numéro deux et je vais lui
dire si je te demande est-ce que 1 et
celui qu'on appelle l'un des six est ce
que tu vas me répondrez vous soit ils me
répondent oui à cette question et dans
ce cas ça veut dire que c'est lui même
l'un des 6 ou alors que c'est un indécis
parce que tout l'intérêt de faire une
question comme ça c'est que même si
c'est à l'un des 6 et que là je
m'adresse aux filous il est obligé de me
répondre oui c'est une question dans la
question donc si c'est le filou qui me
répond et que 1 est l'un des six pour
que vous compreniez bien il serait
obligé de me répondre oui puisqu'il
devrait répondre non à cette question
dans la question mais comme ils m'ont
toujours alors ils obligeaient
transformer en vous en clair on ac le
système et en actes la question et si me
répond non ça veut dire que soit 2 est
l'un des six jeux sait toujours pas par
contre c'est à dire que 1 quoi qu'il
arrive n'est pas l'un des six donc s'ils
me répond non
quoi qu'il arrive je sais que 1 n'est
pas d'un décide donc à la fin de cette
question sur le jeu serait que 1 n'est
pas l'un des six soit je serai que 3
n'est pas l'un des sites j'aurai cette
info la deuxième question je vais
m'adresser à la personne dont je suis
certain que ce n'est pas l'un des six
donc un ou trois suivants la réponse
précédente si je te demande si ses
toiles au net
est ce que tu me dira oui si les lots
net il dira oui quoi qu'il arrive
et donc je sais que c'est le net et
s'est terminée en deux questions
seulement j'ai pu désamorcer la bombe
j'ai même gagné une question eu le temps
de prendre un petit café si ces filous
il doit me dire non alors qu'on
comprenne bien le principe de la
question de la question en temps normal
si la question était franche il sait qui
me diraient non il répondrait pas où ils
répondraient non donc comme c'est un
menteur il doit inverser et me dire oui
et donc au moment où il doit dire oui
comme c'est une deuxième question dans
la question le obligé de ré inverser il
va me dire non et je sais que c'est le
menteur et si c'est le mentor dans ces
cas-là j'utilise la troisième question
pour lui dire est ce que 2 est l'un des
six est inverse sa réponse tout
simplement comme ça je peux déduire qui
est la personne honnête et d activer la
pompe alors la réponse de mike à les
différentes parce qu'elle joue sur une
proportion de valeurs qui est très
intéressante au départ michael je pense
que tu regarderas cette vidéo j'aimerais
bien que m la réponse dans les
commentaires et nous en laye queralt
commentaires pour que ça devienne le top
commentaires et qu'on puisse la voir
tout de suite mais je trouve ça plus
intéressant que ce soit toi qui
l'expliquent parce que le processus pour
trouver ça
honnêtement je n'y aurais pas pensé et
c'est plutôt pas mal de surtout la
première phase
je sais pas si vous aviez trouvé vous
même une autre réponse à ça moi j'ai
bien galéré quand même avant de lui
répondre je dû passer deux trois heures
dessus
hier donc si vous avez une réponse vous
la mettez dans les commentaires et puis
voilà
à demain ciao